[Musique]
avez vous déjà rencontré un animal ou
une personne qui a radicalement changé
votre vie moi oui
cette personne c'est un sage amérindiens
il m'a donné une mission
il m'a dit un jour
karine dealer au delà des mers et des
montagnes dealer commencé chez nous
alors c'est ce que je viens faire avec
vous aujourd'hui
tout a commencé au canada là où je suis
né
j'avais un rêve vivre libres au coeur de
la nature et savoir me débrouiller pour
vivre avec la simplicité de l'essentiel
à 20 ans j'ai senti une profonde colère
monte en moi je me sentais écoeurés par
l'individualisme ambiant par la
surconsommation
j'étais fatigué par la course à la
rentabilité
je me sentais aspiré par la spirale du
temps qui s'accélère chaque jour j'avais
perdu le sens de ma vie de la vie je
ressentais un irrésistible besoin de me
reconnecter à ma vraie nature et d'aller
à la rencontre de peuples qui ont un
mode de vie plus respectueux de l'humain
et la nature
alors pour fêter mes 20 ans je pars
randonnée dans la forêt canadienne
j'installe mon campement au bord d'un
lac
imaginez un immense lac à perte de vue
et tout autour de moi
la forêt la nuit tombe
j'allume un feu soudain j'entends un
bruit derrière les arbres
j'aperçois un regard jaune brillant
derrière les flammes c'est un jeune loup
on se regarde longuement pour mieux
s'apprivoiser
c'est comme si son regard me disais par
karine à la rencontre des peuples de la
nature par il tend saignerons suis ton
instinct ce jour là ma décision est
prise je partirai explorer le monde à la
rencontre des peuples premiers en quête
de leur enseignement
ces peuples premiers
on les appelle aussi les peuples
autochtones
les peuples indigènes les peuples
racines ce sont les premiers habitants
des terres ancestrales sur lequel ils
vivent
ils vivent au bord des maires dans les
forêts dans les déserts paris montagne
ce sont par exemple les inuits du canada
où les massaï de tanzanie où les quais
choix non pas d'un grand magasin de
sport de l'équateur alors je suis mon
instinct et je pars à la rencontre des
amérindiens de mes terres natales en
quête d'une autre vision du monde
ça fait deux heures que je roule sur une
piste forestière
quand j'aperçois au loin une maison en
bois qui fut à côté un will web un tipi
une flamme amérindienne m'invite à
entrer dans sa cabane le soir dans louis
guan assise sur le sol en sapinettes
autour du poêle
je lui livre mon regard sur notre vision
du monde de la nature nous les
occidentaux
nous sommes des prédateurs de la nature
de notre environnement
on cherche à le dominer l posséder on a
les smartphones la voiture intelligente
l'intelligence artificielle la réalité
augmentée le clat le big data et vous
c'est quoi votre vision du monde de la
nature
nous sommes la nature chaque être vivant
à une anne les plantes les animaux
le soleil et nous mêmes les humains
chaque être vivant à sa place nous avons
tous la même valeur nous contrairement à
vous on prend le temps d'observer ce qui
nous entoure de comprendre comment tout
cela s'imbriquent et cohabitent ensemble
en équilibre en harmonie oui c'est vrai
je suis fier d'être anishinabe nous
appartenons à notre territoire nous en
sommes les gardiens notre terre mère
c'est elle qui nous permet de vivre tout
l'amour qu'elle nous donne
nous devons partager avec elle mais avec
tout le monde
c'est notre façon de vivre
c'est comme ça que ça marche nous
formons un tout sa finalité c'est
l'équilibré et l'harmonie
je continue mon exploration sur la piste
indigènes mon instinct me mène en
afrique australe à la rencontre du
peuple san des chasseurs cueilleurs du
botswana ils vivent dans le désert du
kalahari
après plusieurs jours amon la capitale
de rencontres en opportunité mappy
croisent enfin la bonne personne exane
il m'emmène sur la terre de ses ancêtres
nous entamons une longue marche à
travers la savane arbustive le sable
ocre et brûlant 50 degrés sous le soleil
than nuit et pieds nus et trace sa piste
devant comme une aj l'antilope à travers
les buissons aucun doute ce pisteurs
légendaire lit la nature comme un livre
ouvert et même pas mal aux pieds moi je
maire de soi et j'ai les pieds qui brûle
mais dans mes baskets première nuit dans
le désert
allongée sur le sable
je récupère
mais sens sont en éveil tous les bruits
sont démultipliés mais la nuit dans le
désert du kalahari
on entend la musique des étoiles
ça fait plusieurs jours que je partage
la vie quotidienne de la tribu than est
reparti mais aujourd'hui j'ai le droit
un privilège
les hommes m'invite à me joindre à eux
pour partir à la chasse en quête de
gibier pour nous mais nourrir la
communauté alors comment s'organise t-il
pour décrocher leur graal quelle source
d'inspiration pour une humanité durable
les cinq hommes sont en file indienne
devant moi à l'arrière je suis la petite
troupe en silence et je m'efforce
d'observer à la fois l'environnement et
comment je fonctionne dans cet
environnement le premier de la troupe
donne le rythme c'est le plus rapide le
plus agile il tresse la piste dans la
savane au milieu deux costauds qu'ils
suivent à quelques mètres
préservons visiblement leur précieuse
énergie derrière deux adolescents alors
eux ils avancent tranquillement en
flirtant avec les buissons et moi eva je
suis au pas de course tant bien que mal
mais tout en observant
soudain il s'immobilise tous comme sur
un ordre et regardent dans la même
direction
je suis leur regard mais moi je vois
rien de particulier visiblement on
sentit un danger potentiel
la tension est palpable il me regarde
tous pour s'assurer que tout va bien
pour moi
puis le premier de la piste se met sans
rien et le premier pisteurs se met sans
rien dire sur le côté laissant les deux
hommes costauds prend la tête de la file
les deux compères repartent de plus
belle sans hésiter les adolescents
accélère et aussi cette fois-ci
pleinement attentif aux moindres gestes
et regards des deux qui les précèdent
j'ai l'impression que les leaders ont
changé quelle source d'inspiration pour
une humanité durable le soir assises en
cercle autour du feu toute la petite
communauté partage ses histoires du jour
alors pour vérifier mon observation
je pose la question au groupe c'est
qu'il chef ici
le chaman le guérisseur prend la parole
chez nous la communauté est essentielle
il n'y a pas un chef mais des chefs
il ya le chef de village les anciens des
artistes des chasseurs moi même le
chaman le guérisseur ce sont les
circonstances qui impose le meneur de
l'instant n'importe quel membre de la
tribu peut être amené à être le chef
selon ses points forts
parfois ça peut même être des enfants se
sont l'expérience et l'implication de
chacun qui sont primordiales
les chefs
les anciens sont respectés toujours
soutenu leur autorité naturelle
puisqu'elle nous sert à tous
chacun a un rôle chacun sa place comme
il est ici dans la savane
nous devons tisser un lien harmonieux
avec ceux qui nous entourent
être forts ensemble c'est une simple
question de vie et de survie
dans cette quête exploratoire qui
continue encore aujourd'hui j'ai renouer
avec le vrai sens de la vie j'ai compris
le message que m'a livré seul ou au
canada
les sagesse des peuples premiers me
guide au quotidien comme je suis
convaincu que leur vision du monde et
leur mode de vie peuvent nous inspirer
pour construire notre avenir commun
alors quelle source d'inspiration pour
l'humanité durable je ne peux vous
révéler en seulement quelques minutes
la richesse des enseignements des
peuples premiers mais aujourd'hui vous
invite à retenir trois notions
essentielles
premièrement suivre son instinct pour
aller dans le bon sens deuxièmement une
vision systémique du monde qui intègrent
l'environnement comme partenaire
l'environnement qui inclut la
concurrence la conjoncture l'économie
pour une finalité d'équilibré et
d'harmonie
et troisièmement un pouvoir partagé et
tournant basé sur le leadership naturel
et la coopération pour aller le plus
loin possible ensemble nous pouvons tous
contribuer à changer mon environnement
avec des valeurs simples et essentielles
pour une humanité durable maintenant
vous le savez il existe des solutions
inspirante chez ces peuples premiers
aujourd'hui j'ai répondu à la mission
que m'a donné ce sage amérindiens je
suis venu vous dire commencer chez eux
au delà des mers et des montagnes merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]